my talk of the table is the actress
singer dancer and all-around great
entertainer jennifer lewis the 65 year
old has been a recognizable star both in
hollywood and on broadway for more than
four decades jerika duncan she sat down
with the legend who stars in the new
series i love that for you which debuted
this month on showtime part of our
parent company paramount global they
discussed her life legacy and lessons
learned she looks great i was killing
high school majestic in college diva
when i got to new york with jennifer
lewis you never know what you're going
to get
she's equal parts funny
heart and raw talent
with a roster of accomplishments it's
450
episodic television shows
70 movies
concerts all over the world including
carnegie hall you know you go around the
world and you see different cultures and
you feed your soul and for the last
seven years she was part of the soul
that made the tv sitcom blackish
groundbreaking playing the sarcastic
matriarch named ruby let me tell you
about the time i found out how much
arsenic wouldn't kill your grandfather
it's the type of role she's embraced
throughout her career you are
affectionately known as the mother of
black hollywood the first mother i
played was in a movie called what's love
got to do with it anime what you
planning on doing with all that money
honey and it just sort of launched my
career and i went into that mother role
you know
playing tupac shakur his mother you know
i don't line no smoking in here whitney
houston's mother and the preacher's wife
girl
don't be talking to me about your behind
i gave you that behind and then mother
after mother after mother i'm 65 years
old now the joints may go bad when you
get older but the soul is wiser she says
it has taken a lifetime of highs and
lows to find balance born in the small
town of kenlock missouri lewis the
youngest of seven says she discovered
her calling at five years old i knew
what i wanted to be at a very early age
i sang my first solo in church and from
the reaction of the congregation i stood
there with my thumb in my mouth
thinking ah
this is life
and i never look back
after graduating from webster college in
missouri she moved to new york city and
booked her first broadway show within a
month but the next gig didn't come so
easy the elevator to success was broken
as she often says so she took the stairs
instead the unpredictable force that is
life itself
demanded
that i take the stairs one step
at a time
in her memoir she opens up about her
experience with racism being molested by
her family pastor and a battle with sex
addiction i've always said we're sick as
our secrets i laid every secret on the
table
there it is
learn from it however you can
get to the source of your pain
and pull it out from the root
and at the root of her pain bipolar
disorder which went undiagnosed for
years the depression became so
natural i didn't know it was a problem
it was just part of my life when did you
know it was a problem when everybody was
dying from aids i had a nervous
breakdown
a good friend of mine that i respected
said
i think you need help
and i was like oh i'm jennifer lewis
nothing's wrong with me
yes there was i wanted to be happy
i wanted on my face what i
left on everybody else's face when i
left the room which was joy joy
people say mr lewis what does lead with
love mean well what makes you happy
focus on that
and be alive
in living everybody celebrate
leading with love is her mantra for
everything
it's
[Music]
and she spreads that love on social
media i'm 65
hey
and i'm still alive
hey i have no shame about anything and i
have very few regrets because whatever
you did made you who you are right now
very few regrets so what what are the
regrets well that was that one man in
chicago you know
hey come on girl you better just one
cause i read the book well all right
they were about 85 but that's another
story
[Laughter]
she's come a long way from those days
this month she'll be one of the stars in
a new showtime series called i love that
for you
i play the part of patricia
she is the founder and ceo
of a shopping network
and she's an ice queen
is it worth 78 000 because that's how
much pillow mist i've got sitting in my
warehouse taking up space kind of like
you and
i'm saying right now
it's gonna be a big hit
and baby when i call it i call it
the diva turned matriarch now has a new
definition of what it means to be a star
we all have a light
and we allow it to be dim turn it on
baby turn on that light and shine what's
that song this little light of mine
i'm gonna let it shine yeah
this little light but hey but let's
change the lyric too and she was so much
fun
yeah so she is getting her hollywood
star
on the walk of fame this summer she has
a new book called walking in my joy in
these streets which is sort of a play
off of a song she made popular that went
viral online take a listen to our crew
we got a chance to sing it with her
while we were playing
you ready yeah
i don't want nobody
[Laughter]
yes we got everyone involved uh
photographers sound producers we had a
blast with miss jennifer lewis
laugh oh my god the crew on the end was
very amusing yes it was it was a joy and
you know her focus these days she says
it's all about the next generation um
but she is such a light and she has such
a story to tell and i'm so glad that we
were able to do it very impressed by
those birthday leg kicks i'm 65.
i'm gonna try that when i get home hope
we're not calling 9-1-1 she does sarcasm
so well she's great in this new show yes
she is but i love the stories that she's
telling in her candor yeah
and her own life about uh mental health
yeah she's always been open about that
and of course as we recognize mental
health month awareness month um she's
constantly reminding people it is okay
that's right to not be okay to get help
and to talk about it rica that was great
great good stuff